being a highly creative woman I find
myself fearful that having kids will be
spiritual suicide hindering my endeavors
but I also don't want to have an
unfulfilled life can I have a full life
without kids
well yes I suspect you can although it's
risky Maddie because it's really
important for people to have kids
because the thing is is that you get
older than 40 and our culture is kind of
dopey in that regards it's
underdeveloped we live as if we live as
if we only exist when we're young and we
don't it's like what are you going to do
from the ages of say 45 to 90 or 95 you
need a family around you you need to see
your children grow you need to have
grandchildren it's a major part maybe
the most important part of the last half
of life now you said being a highly
creative woman I find myself fearful
that having kids will be spiritual
suicide well that's the part of your
question that I would really address
because I would say well don't let them
be spiritual suicide you know it may be
that there's a certain amount of time
that you need to take away from the kids
then this is the case for parents in
general so that you can pursue your own
creative endeavors this children do not
have to devour your life in fact if you
let them devour your life then you'll
hate them and you'll mistreat them and
so what you want to do is to set
yourself up so that you can have
children and have a life and that's
better for the children and it's better
for you like children can be taught
encouraged to spend a fair bit of time
not when they're infants obviously but
to spend a fair bit of time amusing
themselves that's especially the case if
you have more than one child because
they'll mutually amuse one another it's
actually easier in some ways to have
more than one child because with one
child you're constantly amusing the
child but with two or three then they're
often they're little you know club
especially if you can stop them from
developing sibling rivalry that's too
intense and they can monitor themselves
so the trick is if you're a highly
creative woman this be disagreeable
enough so that you can carve yourself
out your own space so that you don't
come to resent your children you're
afraid of that you're afraid that it
looks like you're afraid that if you if
you give yourself two children there'll
be nothing left for you and you know
that can happen if you have children of
terrible
health problems for example but you
can't protect yourself against those
eventualities in life anyways but I
would say your best bet is to be a more
selfish mother and believe me I've had
more clients who were ruined by mothers
who were too unselfish then I've had
clients who were ruined by mothers who
were too selfish so you need to be there
when the kids need you but you shouldn't
be there any more than is necessary so
let's see
Adam Watts as I feared having kids for
the same reason I'm a full-time pro
artist you make your own normal said my
therapist JP is speaking the truth
yeah well that's the look that's the
thing you know
don't be thinking that you can't
organize your life when you have
children the thing about modern people
is that they're terrified of children
fate in this because they think they
regard children as if they're miniature
tyrants and they can be of course
because anyone will tyrannize over you
if you allow them to perhaps not anyone
but virtually anyone why not regulate
your children's behavior I wrote a
chapter in my new book called
don't let your children do anything that
makes you dislike them and that's like
really serious advice is like if you
allow your children to conduct
themselves around you in a manner that
makes you dislike them if you're being
honest if you're paying attention to the
shadow side of yourself that can be
aggressive and destructive then then
you're if you allow your children to do
things that make you dislike them then
they're going to they're having children
is going to mess up your life but you
don't have to do that you're actually
you actually have a tremendous amount of
control over the quality of your
relationship with your children and also
the manner in which you choose to just
disperse your time and I mean you're
you've got if you're willing to think it
through and be clear you can be in
charge of your household the children
don't have to be in charge and it's not
good for them to be in charge anyways so
people are afraid of children and it's
too bad because children are absolutely
wonderful I mean you have to be careful
with them and they get tired and they
get hungry and they get hot and and they
don't have an attention span that's as
long as an adult who has a long
attention span but they're great company
and they're unbelievably comical and
they love you and like they give back
far more than they take if you have an
ounce of sense when you're dealing with
them so yeah so so don't be afraid of
children man you're you're the adult for
God's sake you've got the upper hand and
if you have a partner you can rely on
well then
you know you can both decide how it is
that you're going to run your household
so that you're actually thrilled to
death that you have kids and that you
have a life